clip 20 Dylan raps about being a girl
overshare my life and you all are still
watching how cool is that
once upon a time I was a boy who had
ADHD and now in the girl who still has
ADHD I really like possums and Twilight
and pretzels I accidentally came an
influencer now here we are girlfriend
[Music]
s women are awesome but can also be
cruel I'm doing my best and boys they
kind of drool my hormones are wild and
my boobs dinosaurs it's only day 200 we
have so much more to experience together
friends you're open-hearted I don't feel
so alone no more shame and carefree
being a girl is awesome would you agree
why would you do that to me
[Music]